thanks to his turn behind the camera for
the new high school chess drama critical
thinking
set for release on september 4th actor
director john leguizamo said he now has
a better perspective on why his
character aurelio didn't make the cut
for john wake chapter 3 parabellum after
he appeared in the first two john wick
films
leguizamo who's making his feature film
directorial debut with real-life story
critical thinking also stars in the
movie as mario martinez
a teacher who in 1998 guided five black
and latino students from miami jackson
high school to become the first ever
inner city school to win the us national
chess championship
in an exclusive interview with looper
ahead of the launch of critical thinking
leg was almost spoke about his john wick
role and revealed why he's okay with
having been cut from john wick 3. as a
filmmaker you know yeah
there's a lot of great performances that
sometimes have to go
and as an actor it's impossible i mean
that part of you
that knows that you did great work and
funny and really inventive stuff that
that didn't get seen having gone through
the film editing process on the other
side of the camera for critical thinking
leguizamo said he understands why
aurelio
a john wick ally who runs a chop shop
was cut completely out of the third
installment
leguizamo told looper with critical
thinking there was a lot of stuff that
got cut that was so
painful then there was a lot of other
stuff that was important in the script
but not so important once you saw it and
you go
i understand that i don't need to see it
it's more powerful if i don't see it
as an actor i don't understand being cut
but as a filmmaker i do
so i have to make peace with myself john
wake 3 actually marked the second time
leguizamo scenes hit the cutting room
floor in the franchise
as the actor noted his role was reduced
significantly during the editing process
for john wick chapter 2.
until i had a fight sequence i had a
backstory i had a whole
a whole plot someday i'll share that
despite the sting of aurelio being cut
out of john wake three
leg was almost said there was a silver
lining i'm cool you know
all this all this stuff leads me to
other other great aspects
of life you know like being shut down
there open this up
you know if i'm doing john week three i
wouldn't be doing critical thinking
but now that critical thinking is
completed and is available to the masses
would leg was almost considered
returning to play aurelio in john week 4
and or 5 if he got the call from the
filmmakers
after all it's unlikely john wick is
going to suddenly lose interest in cars
yeah you know if they ask me i'm not
going to say no i'm not an idiot
critical thinking debuts on video on
demand on september 4th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one